hello everyone and welcome to the Grand
final of the chess bull masters Division
One winner section and it's not even the
Grand Final it's actually the Grand
Final reset what I mean by this is that
Fabiana corvana won the original uh
final then Hikaru Nakamura defeated
Magnus Carlsen in the losers bracket to
come back into the winners bracket and
he defeated Fabiano corvana in the Grand
Final and now as Fabi won the original
final uh Hikaru won the Grand Final now
they go into the Grand Final reset where
they will play more rapid games and if
after two uh rapid games the match is
still undecided then they will play one
final Armageddon game and this is that
game that I'm going to show you this is
basically the seventh game of their
match if you're counting the Grand Final
and the Grand Final reset and it's
absolutely spectacular most of the games
have been very very enjoyable if you
have the time I do suggest watching the
entire event the footage of the live
event as I mean it's just completely
action-packed and it's just they're
playing Amazing chess and I really
thought about which game to show I
decided for the Armageddon one because
it's so many so many great secrets were
overlooked due to time travel but that's
where you guys will come in so basically
to give you a quick overview in the
Grand Final Hikaru started by winning
with black then Fabiano retaliated with
black then hikar won the third game with
black and then in the fourth game Fabi
was unable to retaliate he car won the
the the fourth game with the white
pieces thus winning the Grand Final then
they went into the Grand Final reset
Hikaru again took the lead by winning
the first game with black then Fabiano
retaliated by winning the second game
with black and this is now the
Armageddon uh Hikaru got the black
pieces of course uh uh here you know
there's a bidding war before deciding
who gets black in the Armageddon and
Hikaru to everyone's expectation won the
uh won the draw uh he bid nine minutes
and six seconds and Fabiano bid 9
minutes and 58 seconds uh of course uh
everyone kind of knows that Hikaru can
go lower than Fabi because he is pretty
much the the fastest player in the world
okay maybe it's uh it's here and there
with Magnus but um other than Magnus I
don't think anyone can bid lower than
Hikaru and that means that now Hikaru
has nine minutes and six seconds and
Fabiano will have the full 15 minutes on
the clock so that being said sort of a
quick overview uh let's check out this
spectacular game Fabi opens with C4 he
goes for the English opening we have
Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and E5 now
remember Hikaru only needs a draw to win
the entire event and now uh no uh Four
Knights of the English like we've um
I've been used to seeing in this
tournament we have the Carl Berman
system with Ponte G3 we have C6 and now
Pawn to D4 sort of a reverse Sicilian
with e captures and D4 Queen characters
on D4 and now Pawn to D5 nothing new
here this is the Karis variation Bishop
G2 and D captures on C4 offering Queen
trade but of course Fabi needs a win so
he keeps the Queens on the board Queen
captures on C4 and the bishop E6 with
Queen to A4 and not Bishop to C5 he
can't just continues developing pieces
Knight F3 H6 and both players Castle so
castles castles with Knight beater these
and I uh sorry the first queen queen
back to C2 Knight beat to D7 and now
Pawn to B3 now preparing to think after
the dark Square Bishop as well really
slow playing this as one should when
needing a win and now Rook day there is
a game where Queen t7 was played but
here Hikaru plays Rook to E8 and it is
now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game and this is where
our game basically begins we have Bishop
to B2 by Fabi uh Queen to E7 and now uh
Rook 8 D1 just uh getting the Rooks on
the open file rotate the D1 we have
Ponte E3 and now Bishop to G4 just
pinning that Knights to be annoying
saying that okay if you want to kick it
away you have to play something like H3
and G4 uh other other than that uh I
mean I'm perfectly fine with my Bishop
being on G4 4D
uh for the entire game so here Rook to
D2 Fabi prepares to double up on the
default it's it was basically the first
uh uh think moment of the game up until
this point bald players were just
blitzing out moves so far we decides on
this plan he wants to double up on the D
file and Hikaru is very happy with this
he wants to trade Rooks along the D file
so Knight of Fate Rook characters with
Rook captures and now Pawn to H3 maybe
not the move you want to play uh but you
have to create imbalances in the
position if you are at to look for the
win so here Bishop back the C8 by Hikaru
and now uh just a nice Knight to EQ we
have Bishop to A3 now offering a trade
of Bishops and of course Fabi declines
Bishop to D4 we have C5 by Hikaru being
very annoying at the tafabi's bishop and
here everyone was expecting Bishop back
to A1 which is uh he uh father played
Bishop to B2 and he really helps he
cover there because here hikaru's Bishop
isn't doing all that weight it's an A3
it can't really go back it's not doing
all that much and Fabi should keep the
Bishops in the game point is that now
let's say queen T4 you offer Queen trade
there are funny moves like Knight F to
D4 now you attack Black's Queen and if
you trade just Knight captures on C2 now
attacks that weird bishop and if Rook
the D2 going after the Knight okay you
can just trade captures captures and
after let's say Bishop captures on F6 G
captures and F6 and this is what you
would get um
uh sort of an equal position but he
calls the pawn structure in front of the
king is messed up and you can look for
chances there yeah but uh Fabi decided
uh to bring the bishop to B2 and now
Hikaru just trades it Bishop captures on
B2 Queen captures which was the original
plan and plays B6 and now Hikaru is just
incredibly solid instead of that weird
dark Square Bishop now he has a
beautiful light score Bishop the ponzer
and dark squares the bishop will come to
be seven counter the light Square Bishop
on G2 uh he can be very very happy here
so Pawn to A3 uh Fabi preparing B4
Bishop to B7 and pawn to B4 always in
excellent move with knights the E6 uh
Hikaru gets the Knight back into the
game and now Rook the C1 with Knight to
E4 and now Knight the F4 uh we have
Knight six the G5 and now we have
Knights the H4 by Fabi here in the uh in
the during the live commentary Robert
has said that this is uh you know such a
hard position to push for the win but
you should definitely consider something
like night the H5 the threatened mate in
one because Hikaru already blundered The
Mating one in this tournament so he
might do it again you know it's a not a
bad try and the Knight H5 is in fact the
strongest most room recommended by the
engine but okay Fabi went for Knight to
H4 uh he uh okay I I always remember
Josh waitskin when I see a move like
this because he constantly repeated this
it's something that his uh teacher Bruce
pandolfini taught him uh always uh you
know be mindful of the square left
behind and hereby leaving the F3 Square
you've uh lifted the D2 Square
unattended sonai now Hikaru has this
Rook to DT move which looks very scary
it attacks the queen it goes after the
F2 Pawn and the problem is uh uh well
well it is definitely a move that hikar
wants to play there's Knight F5 and it's
just very annoying the black queen is
now attacked mate is being threatened uh
and you would have nothing better than
to trade here captures captures with
checking if it Knight F5 and you have
this position where there's nothing
wrong with it for black black it's even
very happy playing this it's just that
it's very uh you know chance uh for both
sides so Hikaru doesn't want that he
plays G6 instead now he no longer allows
the Knight to come to F5 and Rook to D2
is a big threat and of course now Fabi
just is rooked Rook the C2 King to H2
was a safer move but he plays Rook to C2
and sort of completely blunders the game
it was not spotted during the game
however you guys will solve it of course
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Hikaru while I give you a
couple of seconds
foreign
who are able to do it congratulations on
finding this beautiful pong grab and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Knight captures on G3 that's
the move so congratulations to everyone
who founded you are a true pong Grabber
AT heart and the reason is you cannot
recapture this you can't play F captures
on G3 you can't trade and then if
captures on G3 none of it works and now
you've just grabbed the pawn I'm gonna
quickly uh show you what happens if uh
for example F captures on G3 there's
Queen captures on E3 with check and now
after King to H1 look at this Rook to D1
how do you stop Checkmate Queen to G1
you have to play Rook to F2 now block
the queen but now Bishop captures on G2
Knight captures and G2 and now the
spectacular Quinta E6 threatening mate
uh G4 and now Queen to D6 with check you
have to interpose with the Knight now
comes Knight to the E4 and there are no
more moves here you're gonna capture on
F2 and then you're gonna deliver a check
and that's it and the The Rook cannot
move of course if you if you move the
Rook away from the second rank then Rook
the D2 right away and there really are
no no moves here that that white can
play so that's the problem after Knight
captures on G3 with actually capturing
the Knight if you play Bishop capture
some B7 just Queen capture some B7 and
now the idea is the same also Queen to
H1 is being threatened so you have to
play King to H2 uh and now Knights the
F1 with check now King the G1 only move
and now Rook to D1 threatening all sorts
of nasty discoveries and now if Rook to
C1 now you have Knight the G3 with check
now you can't take the Rook because of
Queen to H1 Checkmate so you have to
again run with the King now comes Queen
to H1 with check you run the king of the
board Knights the E4 with check King to
G4 and H5 with check and that's pretty
much it
uh the black king and the wild King has
no squares you're gonna have to play
something like Knight captures on H5 but
then G captures with check then you pick
up the rook and then you're just up a
full Rook so that means that if you
can't capture and you can't capture on
B7 the only thing you have left is the
ignore this Knight but what else is
there to play Rook to D2 it's a it's a
move uh but you just read let's say Rook
captures Queen captures now Bishop
captures and G2 King captures and Knight
goes back to E4 you're up upon you have
spectacular Knights the the whites King
side is ruined this will be a slow win
but Hikaru would win this so that was in
the position but he currently missed it
he played Rook to D7 it's a sort of a
this uh
uh Armageddon mindset where if you have
the black pieces you you know you're so
focused on not losing that you sometimes
will miss winning idea so uh Fabi now of
course spots it he plays King to H2
stops Knight G3 and now King to H7 we've
Rook to E2 now uh by Fabi uh B counters
and C5 was maybe the way to go because
now I have to Rook T2 Hikaru just pushes
C4 and now he already creates a sort of
a second weakness uh the the the the
past C pawn and okay Queen to C2 Fabi
has a very clear idea of why he did this
he had to clear the C2 Square for the
queen and now he will have incredible
pressure on that G6 Pawn with both of
the knights with the queen and the ones
F3 lands then of course you know that
Knight captures and G6 is coming so okay
B5 Hikaru also has to defend uh his pass
pawn pawn to F3 now and knights to D6
and here an incredible moment um
arrives where uh of course you know that
Fabi will give up the Knight on G6 the
question is which Knight and I uh Knight
the age captures on G6 is the way to go
and this is um uh what I thought was was
a bit natural because maybe later on you
can push H4 and so on uh but it's uh uh
the the correct move for a completely
different reason and I will show it to
you uh point is that after Knight
captures F captures and queen captures
on G6 King to h8 you will play Queen
captures on H6 and after King to j8 now
remember Hikaru is satisfied with a draw
so he doesn't mind the repetition uh E4
and now after Queen G7 you will trade
Queens that's the point captures
captures and now H4 that's why it's
important to capture with the H Knight
so you have this H4 move in and now
everything for white comes with Tempo
night stage 7 Bishop H3 all of a sudden
attacks The Rook rookie 7 E5 is coming
Knight the E8 uh and now Knights the E6
check with F4 F5 coming and yes why down
a piece but white is the one pushing for
a win here and there are good chances
white will win this position however
Fabi played Knight F captures on G6
because of course he has um doesn't have
all the time in the world and you have
to make a decision now the problem is f
captures Queen captures with checking to
h8 Queen captures on H6 came to G8 and
now uh the problem is you don't have
this um same plan of of trading queens
and then just playing H4 because there's
a knight on H4 so here we have E4 he car
does play Queen to G7 and now uh like I
said you can't trade here like captures
captures and now you don't have H4 you
don't have Bishop to H3 and everything
is not as as it should be so here Fabi
kept the Queens in the game Queen to H5
was played and now hikarp plays Rook the
E7 to stop Pawn to E5 but now Hikaru is
the one that blunders the game and uh I
mean incredible as it is feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
Fabi while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that I
was only tricking you Rook the eve Rook
D7 does not stop E5 and that's exactly
the move you should have uh found uh and
the point of the move of course is Pawn
to E5 the problem now is there's no good
move if you if you do nothing then F4 F5
F6 is coming and if you actually trade
here which you can you're you're
defending D5 squared uh twice Rook
captures Queen captures now look at this
F4 attacks the Knight attacks the queen
attacks the bishop uh how do you play
this there's no no way out of this the
the best way is actually Knight to F3
checks sort of trying to win the White
Queen but now comes Queen characters on
F3 and okay you don't mind giving up the
queen because the black queen also hangs
F captures Bishop captures King captures
and now let's say Knight to F7 attacks
the pawn just E6 now you're up two pawns
uh you are completely winning and that's
what Fabi should have played but he
played Rook to D2 so uh Hikaru through
once fought me through it once now again
it's anyone's game Knight Gita F7 uh
Hikaru now uh or guards the E5 square
sufficiently and also the knights are
now defending each other Queen to C5 and
now we have Queen to F6 guarding the
Knight here uh Rook to D4 by Fabi it's
uh it's a weird move I have no idea what
what it does uh probably the idea is at
some point E5 you give up the pawn and
then Rook joins the attack then maybe
that you can play something like F4 the
bush comes into the game so probably
something like that but after Rook to D4
uh Hikaru just played Ponte A6 which is
interesting as the position also called
for a rook to C7 it's uh it's a move uh
yeah if if Queen captures then Queen
captures on D4 and then you just escort
the pass C Pawn down the board but the
real question is what happens if Queen
captures an A7 and just keeping an eye
on The Rook here now the idea is C3
again white white isn't in time to
defend the pawn look the one C2 Rook to
C1 Queen to beat you and now you will
struggle immensely to keep the position
alive but of course you will fail Knight
C4 attacks the queen let's say queen F4
Knight seat to E5 and once Knight the D3
lands that's it even if you defend it in
just Knight to D3 you don't care because
if Queen captures Queen uh Queen
captures on C1 Europe material you are
completely winning
uh but Hikaru missed it he played A6
again it's the the problem of the of the
Armageddon mindset you are not looking
for for a way to win with black you're
just looking for ways not to lose and
here Rook back to D1 by Fabi we have
Rook day eight and now Rook to E1 now
Fabi is again ready to push the E Pawn
but Hikaru starts pushing the C Pawn uh
we have Queen to E3 now again uh
preparing to push and also keeping
around at C1 square and now we have
Knight the C4 kicks the White Queen back
with Queen the A7 goes after the bishop
and now again if Hikaru was looking for
uh ways to win and keeping this position
alive he would just move the bishop and
continue focusing on the C Pawn but he
went for Queen to B6 he said let's trade
Queens once we trade Queens there's no
way you're you're winning this game so
Queen captures on B6 we have Knight
captures and V6 and now Knight to F5 now
uh Fabi will try to to create some
threats against the black king and get
those pawns pushing up the board Knight
the E5 by Hikaru f form we have knighted
the D3 attacks The Rook Rook the E2 and
now Knight the C4 and now hikaru's
Knights are deadly here Knight to D4 uh
now comes Rook to d8 attacks the Knight
Knight C2 and now Knights the C1 attacks
The Rook Rook to E1 and now even Rook
the D2 this is a spectacular move by
Hikaru he doesn't care about his Knight
hanging on C1 he just plays Rook to D2
and puts pressure on the seat tonight
saying okay I want you to capture here
and there really is nothing better so
far be captured and now look at this
bishop captures an E4 uh by sacrificing
the piece on C1 uh Hikaru removed the
defender of the pawn and now Bishop
captures and E4 becomes possible and you
can't really defend if you move the Rook
then the night Kings so he tried Knight
the E1 to defend the bishop on G2 but
not just nice to E3 a triple attack on
the bishop on G2 and unfortunately it
cannot move so King to G1 now he car
starts collecting with interest Knight
captures and G2 King F1 Knights the E3 a
king to G1 and here Hikaru played C2 and
it was in this position on move 56 that
Fabiano caruana resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
truly truly an incredible match uh just
going back and forth first Hikaru wins
then Fab equalizes uh Hikaru wins five
equalizes then the Grand Final goes to
Hikaru then they go into the Grand Final
reset again Hikaru wins Fabi wins and
now this is truly uh truly a worthy
Armageddon game uh I mean like I said if
you guys have the chance do watch the
entire live broadcast
um it's it it it was truly an amazing
show so here of course you resign
there's no defense against Rook D1
whatever you play like G4 just Rook D1
and you resign you either pick up the
Rook or well you you pick up the Rook
that's pretty much it there's no other
way to put it uh so yeah very nicely
done by Hikaru bands back after his
incredible match against Magnus Carlsen
went to the to the finals against Fabi
and took took the whole thing so a big
congratulations relates to Hikaru and
this incredible Victory so that's the
game and a little bit of info about the
match hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Phil Kessler tags Guru
Joshua Hadley uh Christian hubla uh
www.w walkthrough.com and the James
Cashman for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of everything that's happening
in the Chess World but most likely the
next video will be uh first game of the
World Chess Championship match between
dingler and Ian nipponishi so stay tuned
for that see you soon